we talked about how when we were talking
about seals in the ocean a safety expert
who's my friend
Loki my one of my best friend's son he's
just a lifeguard but um and then you
checked with Kelly Kelly Slater and
Kelly elevator goes
I thought he said that and kills serious
well no not necessarily
yeah yeah the Dolphins are at the seals
around that there can be sharks but then
he said that seals will bite you
yeah he said since Brennan was bitten
yeah times a [ __ ] you up yeah see lining
it you better be careful man like
they're not there it's not like Oh a
seal no no you get out of the water get
out of the water alright cuz no
territorial the male's big time and they
are terracing their teeth they're huge
tables of the sea the pit bulls Aussie
don't start saying that through the pit
bulls of the sea the Gymboree up seal
okay you don't say that this is your pit
bulls of the sake I will tell you what
is a sea all right I'll tell you what is
a co you don't wanna [ __ ] yeah yeah look
at all in that's not like oh that's a
sharp seal no they're all like that
they're what nightmares are not gonna
shine doc it's a it's it's [ __ ]
people of the sea do well you might want
to bring up leopard seal
Oh again that's why I think I brushed my
teeth it's like you bring up leopard
seal yeah that's an apex predator now in
the shark now so that's a very small one
that's a baby sir don't you bring up how
big they are
they all have sharpest teeth - well the
leopard seals penguins are everybody's
terrified of a leopard seal and you
should be a little bit scared but the
guy was scuba diving with a leopard seal
and the leopard seal kept brick he'll
hold on seal ever sealed with a sceptile
I there that looks like my brother
that's all my brother looks at the time
my brother looks like that every greener
you know what my brother he's a lot less
my brother he's the leprous every green
room how's the set there's Jay show
Thursday that's so [ __ ] true yeah
yeah Shawn the stomach on stage there's
Jay right about that hey I just made six
million dollars there's Jay yeah there's
it's his demeanor there's chanting wait
bring up um so this guy was scuba diving
in a leopard seal kept killing penguins
and bringing them to him as an offering
look at the size of it please please
look at the size of it you know they're
[ __ ] the other huge
there is killing a poor [ __ ] penguin
but so there is a petition out right now
where people want to change the name
Columbus from the city Columbus Ohio
hill yeah to flavortown
I'm all for after Guy Fieri because he
is a Columbus Ohio native and people
don't want the city to be named after
Christopher Columbus anymore
Oh who's Christopher Columbus was a guy
who did use apparently and I remember
reading about this in high school when
in 1984 he did use smallpox Laden
blankets and gave him to the Native
Americans on purpose pretty he was not a
very he wasn't and a good man nobody was
not racist back then especially
Europeans nobody was human beings
slavery was was everywhere was
everywhere in the world so if you want
to judge everybody in the in the in
history take down all this time we have
to get rid of all the museums all the
museums honey and get rid of all the art
yeah that every artist is done because
Leonardo da Vinci and [ __ ]
Michelangelo I promise you painted the
Sistine Chapel probably weren't as
politically correct as the wool crowd
either so again this is where the
far-left becomes crazy if I were black I
never was comfortable with statues of
robert e lee i was personally never
comfortable with [ __ ] the confederate
flag i just never was i'm much holding
everybody this debates been raising for
way longer than a lot of people have
been alive and the question becomes do
we preserve our country's history even
if it's if it's blighted history we're
not going to take slavery and the story
of slavery out of history books we need
to know and face it it's very important
the same way some of those symbols might
represent a checkered history a bad part
of our history I understand though I
understand hey listen this is the debate
do we do we have to call flavortown
though can we call it like die fury town
here's the thing I would love to rep a
flavor town Jersey I don't care what
type of team it is there's a jersey that
says well there's Columbus was blue
jackets the NHL Dingles yeah
Cincinnati Oh daddy favorite sour flavor
town bangles but I have a town I don't
know
let's go though and they say he's a
great guy he always gives back he's a
great guy alright so don't dye your hair
like that not because he's a great
you don't die you're scared like that
and not be a great guy we should get got
a [ __ ] pod copy they take us to
flavortown
I take us a flambe daddy tell fury taste
he took us a fine for town its loans if
flavor it was good any rides with dr.
pepper he's proud of he's he's very
confident with food he look even go put
that in your mouth
check that out try that tell me what
happens I don't I'm did I go are we
going to flavortown is this a one-way
ticket of flavor say baby ba thanks guy
yeah I think he's got some mone - oh I
don't know I don't think he flies after
market captain of flavortown you kidding
me yeah he's doing you take us the
flavor baby what else you like
tailgating guy you never had done it did
it once where they were trying to fry an
entire turkey and in a goddamn a yes in
a deep fryers by the way I would imagine
it would be dangerous you know why
because if the turkey is like fault
solid and you drop it in it was great a
lot of [ __ ] meat rocket and it you
know it kills people really oh yeah
every single year people die but Solan
has died you might be making that up
notes on a story I've heard people dying
from you definitely we get burned by
that what dude a frozen flesh turkey
yeah flying it your [ __ ] face that
would be bad that would be very bad yeah
there you go
well there you go that's what happens
but how many people have died trying to
deep-fried Turkey well that's a deep fry
fry there's problems man I've always
been scared of it although mighty
delicious tradition de France Turkey I
think sin can be risky every year deep
fryer fires are responsible for five
deaths Wow
60 injuries the stretch of 900 more than
15 million property damage well be
careful of frozen turkeys okay problem
is very hot oil hey I don't like turkey
in the first place the only turkey I've
ever liked is that truth BBQ you tried
it very good
soft delicious off the lights still
turkey though still turkey still turkey
at the end
turkey takes all the energy out of my
body if you go to a restaurant you're a
chicken or turkey it's like why go out
all the same oh wow so when when I want
ice from frozen turkey meets a vat of
hot oil it instantly changes to steam
and expands to 1,700 times its original
volume well that would be an explosion
it can cause the oil to bubble over and
if an oil particle makes contact with a
flame boom you're in trouble you know I
don't like that Google goes boom you
know yeah I'm professional
Oh in our music our language please yeah
let's make you a little more
professional I want you talking like
you're my doctor
Wow don't call me bro what'd I say boom
you're in trouble that's so crazy
yeah I thought I've heard those stories
so I've always been super scared of
frightened turkeys I also don't like
dirt I don't know what this is but do
you know what QA nan is do you know this
Brian
okay so because it's sort of the right
wing ya conspiracy theory or something
like that so this this particular cut
man you've seen him that you see many
many times huh he was wearing a patched
representing yeah he wore patched
representing that cuing on well I think
a lot of his new world or against a new
world order against globalism against I
think I think it's sort of like an
anti-government yes he said he was like
he liked it because of certain messages
were like it's right there you know
where we go one we go all we're
Americans country bill for everybody all
that stuff but then it also has that
other conspiracy stuff that was
dangerous like pizza gate and everything
else yeah and then the UFC has
prohibited people from wearing anything
belonging to that group yeah because the
the actual conspiracy theories or not
there's no there's no truth to and it
harms people oh yeah you have to be
careful yeah there's there's a whole
thing I don't know I don't know much
about it so don't come after me if your
quaint honor I don't know about either
but he saw he was wearing a patch that
kind of represents that yeah I think
Trump was mentioning it I think a lot of
it's against the deep state justice and
and calls into question the collusion of
the media with government I don't know I
have no it was there's so much to read
up on but yeah it's pretty much what
you're saying I do not know I don't but
it's just it was weird that he was
wearing a hot look it up let's see what
it says I mean there's a
Wiki right here but it's pretty long
acquaintance is a far-right conspiracy
theory detailing a supposed secret plot
by an aligned deep state against us
against Donald Trump right and his
supporters theory began to 20 2017 of an
anonymous imageboard 4chan by someone
using the name q' it was presumably an
american individual initially but
probably became later a group of people
right it's that movie V for Vendetta you
know anonymous it's like a knitting
group that kind of wants to fight the
there's a worldwide cabal Satan
worshipping pedophiles who rule the
world essentially and they could control
everything they control politicians they
control the media they control Hollywood
and they cover up their existence
essentially and they would be you know
yeah yeah I mean that's a lot of that's
a lot of organization Apple oh well and
some almond butter oh wow yeah dude I
gotta be on insulin level gonna be
honest your eyes they look good not bad
they look you know bad better a little
better you can see my ear a little bit
like this you see my lids
Cemal it's still got a little under here
other than that I'm gonna be fine why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gift it's a gift it's a gift